es la imagen de lo que pudo haber sido
un horrible desastre dicen las
autoridades la explosión de un artefacto
a bordo de ese taxi en frente de un
hospital un episodio que tiñe de
heroísmo al conductor del vehículo quien
llevaba a bordo a una persona que según
él se comportaba de manera extraña ese
pasajero fue quien perdió la vida en el
que es el segundo incidente en un mes
con una conexión terrorista es lo que ha
llevado al gobierno a aumentar esta
alerta de substancial a grave
lo que realmente estamos diciendo a la
gente como resultado de lo que pasó en
liverpool es que todos tenemos que estar
atentos en octubre fuera muerte a
puñaladas de un parlamentario el domingo
fue un suceso que llegó en una fecha
clave para los británicos se conmemoraba
a los caídos en guerra ya pocos minutos
de que comenzara un servicio en la
catedral del liverpool cerca de donde
transcurrió la detonación el gobierno
afirma que no puede descartar que haya
una conexión entre esa congregación y la
explosión
hay una investigación en marcha en este
momento y eso va a necesitar tiempo y
espacio para hacer el trabajo que están
haciendo en términos de analizar el
incyde
el reino unido- mantenía su alerta
terrorista en substancial desde el mes
de febrero ahora bajo la etiqueta de una
amenaza grave se considera que un ataque
es altamente probable